en este vídeo hablaremos sobre qué es
unión pero antes de hablar sobre iones
hablemos de los elementos por ejemplo si
tenemos carbono el carbono es un
elemento y supongamos que tenemos un
átomo de carbono pero qué sabemos de ese
átomo de carbono bueno por definición un
átomo de carbono tiene 6 protones
entonces tiene 6 protones y si es un
carbono neutro tiene el mismo número de
electrones entonces tiene 6 electrones
eso es lo que lo hace neutro tenemos 6
cargas positivas y 6 cargas negativas
pero podríamos tener un ión de carbono
aunque no son muy comunes y la forma de
obtener unión es cuando no tenemos el
mismo número de protones y electrones
por ejemplo si tenemos 6 protones y 5
electrones que sería bueno aún tenemos 6
protones y recuerden que los protones
definen qué tipo de elemento tenemos así
aún tenemos carbono pero ahora con una
carga más positiva que negativa así que
a este carbono lo podemos escribir así
con una carga 1 positiva o incluso
podemos escribirlo simplemente así
entonces este es el átomo de carbono y
este es un ión porque tiene diferente
número de protones y de electrones pero
qué pasa en el caso contrario
qué pasa si tenemos 5 protones 5
protones y 6 electrones que tenemos
ahora bueno recuerden que los protones
definen al elemento con el que estamos
trabajando entonces si buscamos qué
elemento tiene 5 protones podemos ver
que es el boro ahora tenemos por y el
boro neutro tiene 5 protones y 5
electrones pero este tiene un electrón
extra así que tiene una carga negativa y
la podemos escribir como 1
o simplemente como menos así decimos que
tiene una carga negativa entonces este
es el guión de boro porque cuando
tenemos un número diferente de protones
y de electrones ya no tenemos un átomo
sino más bien algo que se conoce como
ion hagamos un ejemplo sobre esto aquí
nos dicen que un átomo de platino tiene
un número de masa de 195 entonces vamos
a buscar el platino en la tabla
periódica el platino se encuentra aquí
espero que puedan verlo ahora tenemos un
átomo de platino que tiene un número de
masa de 195 195 es muy cercano a la masa
atómica que tenemos aquí y contiene 74
electrones 74 electrones cuántos
protones y neutrones contiene y cuál es
su carga ok
pensemos en esto un poco tenemos platino
y por definición el platino
78 protones entonces sabemos que tiene
78 protones pero nos dicen que tiene 74
electrones entonces a simple vista
podemos ver que tenemos 4 protones más a
comparación de los electrones así que
tenemos una carga 4 positiva porque
tenemos más carga positiva que negativa
entonces podemos escribir esto como
platino 4 más
este es un ión de platino que tiene una
carga positiva y el término general para
identificar a un ión positivo es catión
un catión es un ión positivo positivo
mientras que al principio cuando
hablamos del boro en este caso es un ión
negativo este es un año les digo esto
para que nos vayamos acostumbrando un
poco a la terminología y bueno aún no
hemos respondido la pregunta nos dicen
que un átomo de platino tiene un número
de masa de 195 y contiene 74 electrones
cuántos protones y neutrones contiene y
cuál es su carga bueno ya deducimos su
carga y conocemos el número de protones
por definición el platino tiene 78
protones pero qué ocurre con los
neutrones bueno si sumamos los protones
más neutrones eso es igual al número de
masa es decir es igual a 195 entonces
tenemos 78 protones más
n por neutrones y eso es igual a 195
entonces si restamos 78 de ambos lados
de la igualdad obtenemos que el número
de neutrones es igual a vamos a ver si
restamos 70 nos queda 125 y menos 8
entonces tenemos 117 neutrones tenemos
117 neutrones
ok así que la idea general es que si
tenemos un átomo un átomo tiene el mismo
número de electrones y de protones el
átomo es neutro pero cuando se pierde
esa neutralidad ya sea que tengamos más
electrones o más protones y esto se
aplica tanto a un átomo como a una
molécula en ese caso podemos decir que
tenemos unión y si queremos ser un poco
más específicos a unión positivo se le
llama catión y a unión negativo se le
conoce como año